citizens I don't know nikoi style citizens
citizenship Nation we are going to continue
the Kung Fu Panda Journey with Kung Fu Panda
part dose today koi how you feeling excited
for Warfare and Panda High drinks I have no
idea what this plot's gonna be I imagine there's
more celebrities in here a lot of people said
we'd like this one the most really you said
two is gonna be our favorite all right I can't
wait to find out if you guys are correct want
to give a heads up even though we're on top
of Kung Fu Panda 2 at the time of filming
this koi is leaving town I live in the country
for 12 to 14 days so he won't be back for
a while so there's going to be a delay between
Kung Fu Panda 2 and Kung Fu Panda 3 but don't
worry when he's back it's gonna be one of
the first things that we do cover so please
do subscribe and click that notification Bell
to get notified when that reaction is up here
on the channel and also smash that like button
a click or whatever that move is called skadoos
like button and as always thank you to everyone
who followed us on our patreon page for all
the movie reactions that we've been covering
again so many thank you guys uh full interaction
watch long as we single with your own copy
of Kung Fu Panda 2 available for super sexy
Rejects and recover a bunch of stuff exclusively
there one last thing I wanted to mention I
wanted to get Coy's reaction to this the time
of this being uploaded I probably already
have my own in-house but uh real rejects has
a brand new shirt Guardians of the Galaxy
inspired but a little bit more than that koi
look away I'll tell you when I look at screen
hopefully you like this shirt boom koi check
it out oh look at the cuteness that is so
much bigger I'd Wonder isn't that awesome
space babies of the Galaxy yeah guys so uh
one of great way to Source channels by checking
out some of our merch I can't wait I buy that
shirt I wish I had that to the premiere so
cute so cute Guardians 4. alrighty guys Link
in the description box pin comment let's get
to it
[Music] changing the time we did hear Michelle
EOS in this and there she is the peacocks
ruled over gong men City they brought great
joy and prosperity to the city for they had
invented fireworks nice but the sun Lord Shen
saw darker power in the fireworks and fireworks
[Music] Shen's troubled parents consulted
a soothsayer she foretold he would be defeated
by a warrior of black and white
the young Lord set out to change his fate
but what he did next oh healed it [Music]
oh no Shen returned to his parents full of
Pride but in their faces he saw only Horrors
genocide yeah he was banished from the city
forever but Shen swore Revenge he would return
and all of China would bow at his feet all
these characters keep trying to satisfy their
parents a lot of Parental issues in the world
of Kung Fu Panda so this is gonna be personal
for Poe are we about to fear a peacock so
[Music]
Forge the ring I love how metal the prison's
heart and Kung Fu Panda land find more metal
China will be mine [Music] oh we're gonna
learn how Poe was adopted by the goose oh
we have to stop him stay focused
I was doing that with his face
[Laughter]
do it [Music] [Laughter] [Music] so invested
[Music]
your training has paid off what's more they
spoke in the whole first movie Master Shifu
what do we got Pirates vandals of volcano
Mountain whatever it is I will take them down
because I am in a mood [Laughter]
final teachings
uh flow with the water
that's neat
did you do that inner peace
Bandits approaching the musician's Village
danger tell those musicians to start playing
some action music Shifu I'll Master inner
peace as soon as I get back no snack stops
this time
wait are you serious he could have a strong
stork who could handle his weight that's a
lot of story did Poe lose weight he looks
worse I think he looks more toned part of
stamina yeah [Music]
oh hello
get out of the metal leave get out of the
metal they made it clear wings of Justice
[Music]
awesome hell yeah hell yeah oh yeah
oh this one's so exciting [Music]
oh
hell yeah
still so impressive they really do a great
job with that
he's coming thanks mantis cool like a team
I love this Trope that's amazing
oh yeah
wow what an inventive opening fight cool [Applause]
good Cannonball special nice Vista Fury
monkey Viper yes yes bunny
[Music] oh it's like the bridge
oh is everyone okay yes that was an incredible
that was so good that was incredible
[Music] his mom oh
okay what happened I think I saw maybe his
Goose dad made it with that pants that Panda
and he's half goose I had this crazy Vision
I think I saw my mom and me as a baby
oh what's happening he doesn't know I think
it's time I told you something I should have
told you a long time ago the real secret ingredient
you might have been kind of adopted I knew
it how did I get here Dad where did I come
from you came from this it was just another
day at the restaurant time to make the noodles
oh he still has the crate that's cute with
my vegetables had just been delivered there
were cabbages tune-ups radishes
he's the next one on the shirt baby panda
brought you inside you gave you a bath and
again and try to put some pants on you
foreshadowing and then I made the decision
that would change my life forever to make
my soup without radish
oh that radishes joke was immaculate
[Music]
hey he's back the badass animals
no no
I love the character designs of this show
now we've got please leave my house I love
how Sinister this is I love that yeah what
do you want gong Man City otherwise out of
dread that kill for nothing what in the Box
what's in the box yeah it's your parting gift
in that it will part you wow
cool neat
holy [__]
nothing to Peacock could be this good you
are no match for our Kung Fu I agree but this
is
damn whoa
good point blank Canada right out of the face
another genocide Chen has created a weapon
one that breathes fire and spits metal the
firework Go destroy this weapon and bring
Lord Shen to Justice wait a second I mean
how can kung fu stop something that stops
kung fu anything is possible when you have
inner peace you must overcome the existentialism
you're feeling po I think the people are going
to be right if this is about inner peace I'm
the Dragon Warrior it's kind of my job to
save Kung Fu and if I don't what am I you're
my son oh right po it's time goodbye Dad don't
worry Mr ping he'll be back before you can
say noodles I have a father his name is Ben
Parker noodles oh that's sad I hope he learns
to appreciate him by the end let's go family
is inner peace or let's go Bleak kill off
the dead that's the third one
oh
Nate God the dimensions of the entire animation
are phenomenal I want to see these storyboards
because it's so
atmospheric mom honey what are you doing here
we replaced you dear with this lovely radish
frankly does better Kung Fu no no no no the
Jack Black voicing his own father
[Music] it's crazy how the usually a sequel
loses its magic of Wonder pretty fast but
this still maintains a really strong Deering
because you're more invested in him because
you love him yeah it feels like it's picking
up perfectly dinner he
he
instead of trying to escalate Stakes it's
just changing them which I like [Music]
Raging Bull why are you really out here I
just found out that my dad isn't really my
dad your dad the goose
that must have been quite a shock and this
bothers you we're warriors right nerves of
Steel Souls of platinum so hardcore you don't
feel anything that's not true I don't have
any problems with my dad maybe he could nominate
his head before I was born
that's why you can't throw a Thurgood for
that line the delivery of a manta's dad jokes
so far
he used to let me play here beside him promising
Sunday this Throne would be mine do you know
who the voices it sounds like Gary Oldman
I have to hear a little more everything must
be exactly how I envisioned it right and I
invested a little to the left with
there that sounded like Ariel in there yeah
every so often the loud part yeah a peacock
is defeated by a warrior of black and white
nothing it's all happening you can't avoid
your fate that's impossible it is not impossible
and he knows it I saw a panda a Kung Fu Warrior
it fought like a demon big and furry find
this Panda and bring him to me one panda lives
that does not make you right being right makes
me right I hope Michelle yeoh and Jackie Chan
have a Scenic oh that'd be great
oh my God
yikes burn down the city guys
they're oppressing this city corrupt wolf
cops fun hey hey
[Laughter]
you will need help thank you Brave sheep but
it's too dangerous I can't let you it's not
safe to speak right
there Masters ox and crack they're in gong
men jail
you guys probably get out of the outfit now
yeah I'm starting to stay in the outfit anymore
they probably know worth it I want that joke
oh what a great shot yes power great shot
Pac-Man dragon now gotcha
nice work classic the Ferocious master we're
gonna free from those bonds of Injustice no
problem gotta be a key around here no they
wouldn't leave a key around here oh good you
found it [Laughter] he will turn the weapon
on the city then we use a sneak attack we
get inside and then and then you will be stopped
[Music] by the Unstoppable weapon nothing's
Unstoppable except for me when I'm stopping
you from telling me something's Unstoppable
[Music] love like the funky side of this I'm
not letting you stay in this cell I'd like
to see you get me out
like I said you are not getting me out of
the cell
you're mine I'll tell you what's gonna be
yours my fist and your plush cuddly super
Softly oh
I love the like old school Kung Fu exploitation
vibe there yeah like the exposition insults
oh
it's like Jackie Chan's project a oh
cool yes it's like the wheelchair race and
Days of Thunder Tom Cruise and Carrie always
wow [Music] oh my goodness
[Music] we're gonna chase through the city
thank you Kung Fu Panda I love the teamwork
of all them in this movie and the way they
use their animal skills which momentum
[Music]
oh great
great [Laughter]
[Applause]
oh nice
you can chain my body but you will never change
the water they get caught eight point acupressure
cuffs just like the ones that held Tai Lung
the more you move the tighter they get these
are the best cops
was this made for 3D it feels like some of
the shots feel that way greetings we meet
[Music]
if anyone should be afraid it's you [Music]
don't even
I like his like Jafar Voldemort delivery he's
like in both ability he can be menacing but
also take a joke at the same time it's hard
to ride that line good job Gary
[Music] mjolnir my old enemy
stairs [Laughter] God I really have to walk
all that
oh
thanks for caring me those last few flights
okay how do you convince them to care we meet
hey how you doing
hey
laughs
we only heard about master Rhino a few days
ago and we came to avenge him you've come
to avenge no elves well yeah all the pots
and pans that you stole I'm gonna want those
back
I don't know what else did you do
funny oh no that's good really dark who do
you think you are panda who do you think I
am peacock I hope they release these in the
theaters oh that'd be great I'll re-watch
[Music]
destroy the weapon yeah
just don't see a sign po don't get trauma
track trigger PTSD up triggered oh [Music]
I was like Moses
you
just let Shen get away at least we destroyed
the weapon that's true maybe they have another
oh no they have multiple weapons that seems
no [Laughter]
oh no it's dark it's dark I don't like it
I don't like the lighting one minute come
on we need you to focus I got it I got it
I love this one yeah I've been like just encapsulated
the entire time this is such a great movie
whoa
[Music] yes
all right that's what I'm talking about
[Music]
holy [__]
right now the peacock who's that voice I think
it's Seth Rogen also is it yes I was like
I was questioning if they would do like both
Seth Rogen like two people it's just the grunting
sounds it's gonna be someone super iconic
and I'm just gonna throw good
man these sequences are amazing it's just
so much movement it's like a Non-Stop ride
really keeps going you had shin okay he got
oh
just open up open up get Inner Peace by accepting
the peacock was there the last time I saw
my parents I have to know the hardcore can't
understand
what did not expect that
but I can't watch my friend be killed oh they
really gave us what we wanted with from the
last movie which is really spent time and
hang out with the furious five yeah building
relationships like connecting with them yeah
this is how you sequel the dead exists in
the past and I must tend to the Future what
about now
this is like a Fury Road kind of movie where
it just where's like the stories and the action
and everything booms yeah yeah but it's like
that never loses this emotion yeah I I just
can't get over how much movement there always
is yeah it's always so much
of the peacock hey
[Music]
she keeps rolling just to do it yes I watched
as your parents abandoned you it's a terrible
thing I believe it went this
it went nothing like that there was no smolting
[Music]
cool
you looking for me
[Laughter] I said that too soon didn't I like
Terminator 2 reveal
oh just like when his dad put it on a cat
put here let me heal you oh my God he had
one just right there so many cannons
his inner peace has been destroyed it was
great disturbance in the force Dustin Hoffman's
barely in this because he wanted to show his
face more defended he's like I'm just frankly
knocking into it let me sit in a cave or something
is it a panda is it a panda
give me what I want all I'll accept
that's a ram [Laughter] also good yeah like
he could make me drink this [Laughter] where
am I
his original home
[Music] oh no this is really heavy [__]
this is like really heavy childhood trauma
acceptance loss but he just this memory of
the slaughtered God I foretold that someone
would stand in his way a panda but I never
could have foretold what came next ah she
feels partially responsible yeah
oh it's his hammer
remember let it flow you must accept
Tai Chi
this is so moving
[Music] oh [Music]
damn that guy's evil oh that's an evil man
your story may not have such a happy beginning
but that doesn't make you who you are taste
the rest of your story who you choose to be
that's a great message
oh [Music] this is so touching it's so good
it's so touchy who are you panda I have a
father his name is Ben bark I am Poe and I'm
gonna need a hat [Laughter] honestly guys
I never thought I'd die like this I always
thought I'd meet a nice girl and settle down
and she'd eat my head
Lord Shen what about the bridge
oh yeah
you coward
he's got the Hat can he wield like the water
and it's like using a water bender now yeah
what prepare yourself for a hot this joke
before Shazam did it by a [__] it's a
good joke
hmm
that's your freedom funky cut your freedom
what's your plan step one free the five what's
step two honestly I didn't think I'd make
it this far
foreign
there is very persuasive yeah
I didn't see that coming red panda the splits
are back
oh whoa what power move what
sort of talking about man
[Music] [Laughter]
God these perspective shots are great so cool
oh whoa
oh
they did not they wouldn't she's had a lot
of great moments though that's how it works
they wouldn't kill her off she doesn't feel
that she feels did they look up on IMDb right
now
I'm gonna wait
dude wield the water they've been teasing
it make him a water vendor I think it represents
flow but it could also be a power or maybe
she palmed it
oh rage oh maybe he could be on fire
he's super saiyan now because in her peace
there is a wielding of elements in the movie
I can't wait for it to come back to something
I'm like it's a metaphor you're like no he
can wheel water maybe called out lightning
po let's finish this okay oh he's can you
think he'll do the iron Palm thing oh the
20 years of training is happening now I've
been predicting this movie wrong so much I'm
trying to get this down so funny try to get
it down let me have a moment oh there it is
inner peace Matrix bullet time wield higher
wheel the network
inner peace
that's cooler that's cooler that's awesome
[Music]
nice
[Music] all right great video game level I
just want to hear Jack Black in a booth no
[Music] it is [Music]
awesome I I scarred you for life scars heal
wounds heal oh yeah what do scars do they
fade I guess
is what you choose to be now then I choose
this
you need the one-on-one fight boss fight boss
fight oh oh
you chose wrong peacock
peacock chose wrong he accepted his own fate
that was pretty hardcore
[Music] it seems you have found inner peace
and at such a young age
[Laughter] is so good [Laughter] wanted was
to meet the Dragon Warrior when do you think
he'll be back
hey I don't know maybe never why doesn't have
to go and save China I know why
oh crates from where he came from I know who
I am you too I'm your son oh
I love you Dad
let's both cook together to get a no alcohol
there's a there's a whole bunch of their holiday
Panda
that's not the end can you imagine if they
never made parts we think this will do well
oh damn that was beautiful that was beautiful
oh [__] that is really beautiful what
an exceptional sequel I know holy [__]
like this vastly surpassed the first one for
me I love the first one and I was surprised
at how much because it had been so praised
but this was like this was one of the better
animated movies I've ever seen this is he
had a whole other level than me Lucy Liu wasn't
she in the first one [Laughter] I think these
are all the Warriors five still uh who's she
in there she one of the five she's uh she
doesn't talk a lot it took evidently um the
store no Shelia was new she was the ram Danny
McBride oh who sounds like Seth Rogan yeah
okay
what
and Jackie Chan I love how they give him that
little three give him that extra love he should
I wonder if it helps with like China release
oh that'd be interesting and there's also
a nod to like the world they built yeah I
mean Michelle has been part of like a bunch
of action fantasy as well but she was new
to this one right so like Jackie Chan yeah
I wonder if there's like a channel a little
more lines in the third film if there's like
Tony jaw or like Jet Li like they add yeah
oh donut shot is Thai if I'm obviously
they're in Thailand where are the pandas is
that the third movie I want to know that has
to be the third gotta be right it seems like
essential viewing because I was literally
watching I was like it's like an hour into
this going I don't know how you would top
this with like another one yeah and there's
a fourth I know that's been a lot of years
in development though which I like that they're
taking their creative Consultants oh it shines
it shows I love that they're taking their
time oh yeah the character designs some of
the dark Menace yeah the camera work with
a lot of it yeah I think it totally shows
uh I love that they're take they took their
time for a fourth one because you could you
know undermine a franchise this strong if
you just make them you could Shrek it you
could Shrek it and you gotta come back and
Puss in Boots yourself yeah because the the
movie was so effective in every corner and
I thought they really improved and it had
such a had such a catharsis to it yeah you
know I like I really enjoyed the first one
a lot um but this was so much more emotionally
gripping and it's more exciting like it okay
to really lay it out here Master Croc was
John yeah that tracks got it okay so for me
a sequel should go you know deeper and whether
that means more action like as long as it
doesn't cost you the story like a lot of times
Seekers go out and big I like when schools
go in and like the first movie you've got
to set up so much world that this is exactly
what I want a sequel to be like they trust
the audience to be invested in the characters
so you could just like get more rich and then
like the character design I loved how cool
a peacock was yeah and then you're invested
already so you can really go heavy with everything
and then the action is just so visceral and
moving in kinetic that like the Still Moments
are so resonant and the kinetic action is
so much like I could see how a five-year-old
would be just so stimulated but then you can
add like stuff for adults to be grounding
like this is exactly what I want out of animated
film it was a pure Adventure so exceptional
it was a genuine adventure with so much Soul
throughout it and I think they've really nailed
something down with Poe here because it's
easy to make him relatable in the first one
yeah and now that he's Dragon Warrior status
it's easy to lose that relatability and sometimes
what movies will do is like well let's just
make him like behave a little dumb or something
like that in order to maintain that relatability
but they don't rely on that they don't like
they don't Dum him up more or something along
those lines um he's a bit of a doofus as but
that's the character but he's not incompetent
you know and I like that that's a hard lot
to walk it's a really hard line but movies
often botch that and they manage to make him
even more relatable yeah even though he's
the Dragon Warrior now I'm like how'd they
do that he's the god amongst men and he's
also trauma induced like he's got so much
you attached to yeah and they honed in on
the soul of every character here more like
the father and some relationship is every
a lot of things that were just kind of cute
or charming in the first one I think they
really found the a much bigger Nuance to it
like with the dad at the case I'm like damn
that is such a powerful moment at the end
too like you know you you want that ending
when he comes back he's like you're my like
I immediately saw it the second it was after
everyone did when he when he finds out he's
adopted that he'll come back around and be
right here like it's such an obvious beat
but it's about does the movie earn its journey
to getting there and like you want it to happen
to where it doesn't feel cheap and it doesn't
feel cheap it feels rewarding by the end I
love it so many stories are a certain path
that's how you get to that and like resulted
whether it was worth the journey and like
that Journey was beautifully told like the
the Redemption moment for their relationship
was amazing and yeah the way they've elevated
their action I I liken it to uh I don't know
it's like the it man like this we got to do
with action right you always got to up it
in some way yeah but I like how they didn't
just do it purely through choreography like
the first fight they have here it's like you
see his pose part of the team and they keep
that Dynamic throughout but then when they
have like the chase scene going on wow this
is so visually stunning I I found myself see
the first one I was really enjoying from like
uh I really had fun I was observing it you
know it was really fun this one I was I I
would forget that I'm like getting transported
into it to the point I'm like oh there's a
camera here yeah at no point did I think I'm
watching a movie Once 20 minutes were in like
I I stayed so like oh my God it was absorbing
it was an absorbing experience like I love
this uh I like this one I was expecting like
from people like preparing us that would be
better um I always worry I always remember
this was another level to me I'm like this
wasn't I was transported during this one yeah
do I do I like feel as connected and can I
attach when the expectations are so high and
then you add the SQL element to it and it
I think is one of the better sequels like
this was a really special delivery because
you've got all these characters and I think
the team Dynamic evolving with action allows
you to feel the team Dynamic evolving with
them emotionally and then you've got all the
emotion yeah love that like what a stunning
film I really appreciate because yes does
uh let's Dustin Hoffman's character deceiver
the red panda the Red fan but he's there he's
fun it's fun to have him there and I like
how that he sets up the theme of the movie
yeah um so that and then when he comes back
around the end it's great there's also an
element of uh okay good I'll start the post
credit uh they did a thing that I think a
lot of superhero movies try to do which is
at a big Crescendo of action you're so tense
that sometimes a joke works sometimes it doesn't
and there were like three amazing jokes at
the peak of action that um made it better
not worse like the scars fade was so good
yeah like guy doesn't fade I guess like that
was that would have not worked with another
voice actor a different delivery like that
was so spot on wounds heal scars then fade
fade I guess like genius it still seems within
the character as opposed to we need to make
it funny to light it up because it's a kids
movie yeah and like some movies do not get
that difference this really got that and I
I like the I like the choice of the animation
for the flashback when it was more of this
like hand-drawn 2D yeah but then as it becomes
this visual representation when he does accept
what the memory is how it morphs into the
current animation yes I was like oh that kind
of creates a distance and a barrier for him
by keeping him that kind of 2D animation and
then it becomes and becomes one with it with
the current animation I thought that was like
a cool visual representation and like I I
do feel like that acknowledges trauma in a
really unique way that you you when you don't
accept trauma separate from it so like you're
saying once you absorb it into you it's it's
more like your day-to-day life which was really
beautifully told yeah it's a great story about
acceptance I mean you see a lot of stories
that deal with grief and whatnot uh this I
thought did it in a very different way that
really was about like don't let yeah a lot
of themes like don't let the past Define you
you know and move forward but what matters
is what you do today and like there's a lot
of themes in the last one about presence so
they carry the themes on but in a way that
feels organic yeah and not just like we need
a new movie to do right right I guess we should
it made a lot of money DreamWorks having their
own Styles also really lovely I mean Pixar's
got that existential thing down but these
ones have that action adventure plus
morals oh well they gave us the the papa bear
I feel like that would have been a problem
it would have been the post-credit but it
also didn't feel like a post-credit no it
felt like it was where it belonged but I imagine
that like if there had been one Boop I mean
they must have known that this was gonna be
like a massive hit I mean yeah what if I cannot
believe it's a 7.2 in IMDb those Cowarts um
that was excessive really have less of a rating
it is yeah this was it it's also lowering
on tomatoes I feel like um Kung Fu what yeah
how I don't know it said 91 the other 96 if
I remember correctly what right I could be
wrong but I remember looking and thinking
two was lower which doesn't make sense this
is so like I thought this was great and perfect
I thought this was Superior by a lot and I
love the first one but I get the first one
like a B plus a minus border and I give this
one a full a like this is a comfortable a
film to me I I yeah I thought this was excellent
and the villain was great the I like how the
villain mirrored I mean they do such a good
job with both of these movies with the villains
of them mirroring some type of Journey that
parallels our protagonist characters right
but the way they did it with him of of tying
it into something that was it was dark that
was dark [__] that is like not you know
that is a really hard line to ride because
it's like a slaughtering right I mean you
find out they're not dead so probably like
a little bit but not until the last five percent
of the movie it's really at the end of the
movie I'm like damn these guys like it was
really heavy for a while yeah yeah that is
a dark ass scene and the paralleling of like
whether those traumas shape you into good
or evil I loved like him lose his parents
like what you're saying is those those villains
do that and I'm really curious what the third
one does but also the fact that it doesn't
feel like sometimes the villain problem in
movies is okay they're boring because they
do the exact thing in the opposite way yeah
like like the uh for me a big example is a
yellow jacket in ant and two or Ant-Man one
sorry Warriors was like okay I get it villainy
when you have science and power right they
could have very easily made him like okay
he's a bad guy because he lost his parents
he's good guys he lost his parents and at
no point did I feel like the Gary Oldman take
was um lacking the depth of pain or Justified
like he felt completely justified in his mustache
twirling and they gave him a mustache it's
amazing they can get actors like Ian McShane
and Gary Oldman to play these characters and
you really get the sense that they truly let
them bring something to it because it's such
it's so easy to just write off like they're
just villain characters but especially with
they gave Gary Oldman to do here yeah I love
that he was able to weave in and out of being
menacing but also being someone you laugh
at and he like knew when like even that line
delivery of my favorite line deliveries this
most simple one when the when Poe says Hey
react to it he's like upset and uncomfortable
yeah like I don't know how to proceed with
this it was such a well done line and I think
Gary Oldman is is a great casting because
he's someone who you imagine is being a very
serious guy yeah um and but he's got such
versatility when I John and I we saw The Simpsons
movie John and I together and Gary Oldman
was in our row yeah uh years just had like
a regular screening at Universal it was with
his family and he was like cracking up during
the movie and like stomping his feet and it
compli and he had his uh Gordon mustache on
it oh that's great he must have been like
in the middle of film and reproduction or
post-production or some [__] right um
better set it up but he had to see Gary Oldman
who you know is like this super serious guy
just enjoy it yeah like laughing at The Simpsons
Movie I'm like it painted him in a whole different
light to me like oh yeah you got to be a bit
of a goofball to do the kind of [__] that
Gary Oldman does yeah would you go from everyone
into like the chaos of Gary Oldman yeah yeah
uh so I thought he was great uh he was excellent
of course again the the evolution of the animation
with uh you know the weaving in the I don't
know the feather reaction with the peacock
I don't know words yeah the visuals of the
four I always talk about the the fourth dimension
I love the z-axis I love when it brings it
out to you sorry third image when it comes
to you I think is so well done here and then
blending that with the flow State the slo-mo
and all those elements that felt so photorealistic
at points like I was watching a panda Bend
Water and I was like I feel like I'm watching
a like a documentary like it felt so photo
real in those close-ups is there stop motion
a motion capture apply to any of this I don't
think so sometimes they do that like in the
final episodes of The Clone Wars they had
a fight with Darth Maul and they they actually
made it uh I mean everything it was it was
always animated and then for that one they
made it um motion capture I know with Rango
they had the actors actually like which is
why I think that movie is so visually unique
so they get an actual snake to do something
do you think the panda I love the third Act
of the movie we're like is he gonna is he
gonna maybe I was trying to just predict something
I don't know the obvious like I'm gonna come
around to you Dad but give me some surprise
I love that it subverted your expectations
that you kept throwing at it I thought he
would wield fire or something that was so
good that was such an a film like that is
so comfortably I'm surprised that it's got
a lower I'm 90 what what is what is the rating
let's find out okay Rotten Tomatoes and I
don't want to know who's in the third one
so I'm gonna be very careful not yeah I've
enjoyed this because I had a slight bit of
familiarity with the first one but um I had
no familiarity wait let me know when how recent
the third one is because this came out in
2011 according to the credits okay Kung Fu
Panda uh okay the first one wait there's a
show positives okay I don't know I'm gonna
type in two uh 2011 81 oh wow that is low
for what that just was what is the consensus
um storyline Arc may seem a tad familiar to
fans of the original it is so different from
the original Tad familiar there is so little
to do with the first one like he literally
goes on a completely separate Arc what are
they talking about he leaves home like there's
nothing in the first one in this the opening
is different like it's a continuation but
if you want them to be like different characters
that consensus is [__] what's okay I'm
gonna try Okay so that's 81 for the for the
new one uh the first one got a yeah don't
look up I'm trying to not touch anything don't
look up three literally don't three the reason
eight yeah okay I'm literally like hiding
half my phone so I can just see the date go
scroll click the time 87 87 oh okay it's not
that far off six percent but it's better yeah
no it is better I'm surprised but like 87's
approaching an A and that was like a low B
that's shenanigans I don't know what people
say position maybe 19 lack of Dustin Hoffman
that's it the red panda was ended up but 19
of critics like however many vote I don't
know I don't want to read too much but like
19 thinking it's less than a three that's
silly we must get more Tigress backstory in
the in the next one yeah I mean you see a
little bit of it of how she wanted to appease
red panda [Music] but we don't but we did
this one really hints a lot more that's another
thing it's Angelina Jolie they actually like
let her be a freaking character this time
yeah this one I actually felt like they utilized
her voices
they were trying like let's give him like
a couple of lines to cut into yeah Michelle
Yo's lines in here equal more than Jackie
Chan's lines in both this one and the last
100 guaranteed I don't know why I think uh
they leaned into the Rogan Comedy perfectly
too the Mantis jokes were so good for me like
I really love those yeah I feel like they
finally found that like mix of we have these
actors we've established them we have these
characters and now we let the actors do the
thing we have higher than four more here um
I thought this was a brilliant brilliant sequel
uh I loved it I would give it me personally
I did this like a 99 yeah I thought I I don't
know it was like 95 96 for me what do you
not if you had to find something to pinpoint
that you didn't like honestly the little short
uh and my biggest flaws I wanted more of it
well there was times that I was like okay
I'd love to see a little bit more of this
element this element but not in a bad way
that's going to drop it from an A to an even
an A minus but like for me there's no such
thing as perfect I've only given 20 movies
five stars so it's just like that is an element
I like Jimmy and I've only ever seen I think
there's literally 20 movies I consider perfect
well he says that's weird because I feel opposite
I I feel like this felt longer than 90 minutes
but in a complimentary way oh interesting
yeah see like I wanted to live in the first
act a little bit more and like reacquaint
myself with everybody because if I feel like
if I hadn't seen the first one a week ago
if I'd seen it like four years ago like everybody
else I'd want to be a little bit more in the
in the fun zone of like remember your friends
oh really you know what I mean oh I mean that's
weird wish but we didn't watch the first one
I won but yeah but I'm watching it with the
eyes of someone that like imagined just watch
it with your horizon your experience but like
you've got to know when it came out in response
to the first one I would just watch them I
was like I watched but that's kind of like
the issue that I think some people running
with guardians three yeah is like I because
I watched all the movies in one week it like
literally watch holiday special next finished
holiday special the next day went into Guardians
three I was like oh this is perfect yeah you
know but then there's a lot of people who
are like oh I want more Groot I'm like but
you got plenty yeah oh yeah yeah I mean I'm
gonna re-watch them from my re-watch but I
didn't have time for my first watch so I'm
actually curious how that affects it yeah
but I will acknowledge that like I've most
people are gonna have watched it in the last
week oh of course yeah no a thousand percent
you're right I mean who knows over the years
because people probably also binge I also
wish we had time for three before I left I
was like damn we should just do three yeah
because like that was exceptional that was
that was amazing um but no I think it'd be
good to get some distance then we could actually
see it through the lens of not having seated
back tomorrow so it's like a 10-year Gap isn't
it isn't it or like this who says seven yeah
it hasn't even been 10 years uh since uh wait
no it's been 12 in real life
uh no I thought it came out I don't know I've
never even seen a trailer for it I assume
it was in the in the late teens because of
the um I thought it was like 2015 or something
oh then maybe they did like a one-two punch
because the ending like because of the panda
and I think I would have to come out a little
closer maybe they have the t's yeah maybe
that already like started work on it like
Lord of the Rings yeah I don't know I love
how little we know about all of this I was
like hiding the dates on my photos Rotten
Tomatoes because I like that might give context
of who the bad guy is like what actor's gonna
be the best other than Kung Fu Panda 4. next
year yeah they said 2024. okay cool we'll
do an out of the theater reaction in a year
this is where I try to convince koi to skip
the theater
to do reaction together here do you think
they'll do it in like a 45 day window or do
you think that'll be dead by then well actually
funny enough I mean I was so close Mario at
the time of filming this Mario comes out on
VOD next week yeah and I was like oh I want
AMC still playing an IMAX but then I realized
oh wait right now but then guardian's gonna
push it out and then a couple days later after
Guardians comes out then Mario goes on video
100 that is all part of the plan so I'm like
maybe we'll get okay I skipped 65 so I could
watch it on the number one hit of the summer
we're going on this journey quantity it's
going to be a year of me trying to convince
koi it's probably gonna be I mean it might
succeed I love the theater experience but
this has been really fun doing these with
you so maybe out of honoring the scenes the
honoring it's gonna be like my battle between
loving exhibition and the series that you've
if you want to be watching Kung Fu Panda 4
if you weren't watching one two three over
here that's true all right well join him in
uh in that quest to get me to skip at the
after the release yeah a thing I don't do
we'll see we'll see maybe I might change my
mind
all right guys well thank you so much for
being here thank you I hope you have fun and
wrong I hope you're having fun right now right
while you're there um hey guys leave a like
subscribe keep a lookout for Kung Fu Panda
3 we'll try to get it to you within the month
at least and please take some time to put
together people and uh yeah go get yourself
a space baby shirt too peace very very soon
but let's end this with the
Chase Gardener Chase my friend thank you so
much for being here um we're gonna do a special
kind of shout out because we saw that you
commented on our watch Along on patreon and
you are one of our patrons who qualifies for
us a special dedicated shout outs we're gonna
answer a question oh I like it Chase is asking
have you guys seen How to Train Your Dragon
Trilogy series highly recommend after you
watch these movies love Kung Fu Panda well
koi I you actually koi gave me an answer about
this before we started Kung Fu padness so
take it away koi I consider How to Train Your
Dragon one of the only perfect trilogies I
think uh that should be in conversation with
Back to the Future with Lord of the Rings
with the Before Sunrise Trilogy How to Train
Your Dragon I think all of them are Immaculate
and uh I honestly it's one of the most emotionally
investing series I've ever experienced I truly
love that series and uh was lucky enough to
go to the premiere of the third one and tell
everyone that made any of them how much I
loved it it was really funny to see uh animators
get their like their do love and that whole
team's wonderful well my answer is oh it says
Greg answer uh I was on you know a certain
kind of Gregory how do you and gummies for
many years a period of time there's like a
solid like eight years in my life and I saw
one definitely like that all I remember is
one scene where toothless of being like hey
even like a cat and then I saw another and
then in part two I'm pretty sure I saw that
in the theaters but I don't remember it's
such a blur it feels like a nightmare to me
and three just came out too and I I saw three
I honestly have no wow what the plot is I
can't it's the second one does something to
do with the mom right yeah and they find out
she's alive yeah that's what I remember remember
feeling like a nightmare scene and the dad
dies yep and then the third one sorry if I
spoiled How to Train Your Dragon for you but
that that's all I remember is being in the
theater just the emotional totally on something
and being like this is like a nightmare you
gotta re-watch those but then uh yeah so that's
the thing I can't I can't watch it here because
I remember that plot Point too well uh even
though I don't remember anything else surrounding
that one scene he'll be talking about this
team well I remember this how do we get to
that everyone see the three yeah I can't remember
for the something to do with a pirate was
it a pirate so basically the dragon Kingdom
has been destroyed and then they find out
there's other Dragon kingdoms and there's
a piratey-like villain yeah you should watch
them they're really good they're so good
I don't remember um
thank you I was able to say J Bar Raquel every
time I'm just like Jay yeah uh between Hiccup
and him and I love the parallel of like they're
wounding I love that like the costumes evolve
and like it's one of the few animated series
that I can think of where like a thing will
happen to damage a character and they'll use
that as either a plot point or like a visual
reference in the next one so like scars impact
things and clothing evolves and all the relationships
between like the Viking warriors are cool
and like Gerard Butler's it's so good it's
so good and Jay barkel so slept on as a voice
actor he's Immaculate well Chase we gave you
an answer that you probably could have been
like yeah we've seen it but we we went for
it we went for it just to give you a detailed
answer there Chase thanks so much for being
here buddy and showing your support we'll
talk with you all soon [Music] thank you